Jerry Jones and Trish Suhr want Roger
Goodell out New York Giants coach Ben
McAdoo says quote we have a run in US
and WNBA superstars illidan ties the not
in heels
this is sports without balls oh my god
we are live in the ATC podcast studio in
an undisclosed location in Burbank
California
however Trish Suhr just sprayed our
microphones with some sort of floral
tropical Thunder so we might be also
recording in a Macy's department like
did you tell them why our mics smelled
of like beef and tobacco it wasn't
romantic very real manly very musky and
not in a hey let's hit it kind of way
more of a like dear God there might be a
murder nearby what yeah I smelled the
touch of dead body just a skosh to my
right hostess with the mostess Trish
Suhr holy intimate right we've got our
guests back back back NFL correspondent
one of my favorite people a fantastic
stand-up comic played football
Jenny McNulty we are also recording this
hi guys
lots of new stuff let's start the
episode before we get Jenny involved oh
oh my god I'm sorry I just I dropped one
we had a slight drop one of the balls
I'm gonna pick them up - Jenny's right
we've got Erin in the booth hey Erin hey
go cards offseason offseason hey what's
that hat you're wearing by the way super
sweet it's uh the oakland a's batting
practice hat
vert I put it on Instagram because Erin
looking sharp today I went to the
stadium
oh that's right I remember that I went
for fourth of July so fantastic Bears
hat dude I'm laughing with a bat that's
what I thought it was yeah that's cool I
told Erin the next couple months for him
are gonna be a little bit rough as we're
doing everything non baseball but now
we'll get will
do some January like a Winter Meetings
oh so he perks up in the corner it's
some smelling salts and oh yes or the
tropical Thunder I don't know why I'm
calling it that way dela by Stella
McCartney oh thank you I have an
affinity to Paul so I supported his
daughter oh wow and I have an affinity
to blonde so it's all coming together
alright before we jump in
I just wanted to announce a couple
things that are happening behind the
scenes at sports without balls Trish and
I are taking her game up 75 noches oh
yeah
besides our big social media pushes on
Instagram and we're posting more on
Facebook
behind the scenes we've got a new
website coming we've got a merch store
coming 2018 is going to be a home of
more live events and we're going to have
on the website that's coming we're going
to have a patreon button to be for a
group of subscribers we've got a PayPal
because people email constantly can I
donate to the show which all gets put
back into sports of that balls and like
the true businesswoman I am
I have not set that up apparently I
don't like money we're working on it
don't worry what kind of Tricia's you
know all things social media and a
business guru and I don't want to be
homeless so it's all coming it's working
out you guys and it's gonna be super fun
and I cannot wait for you to see the
merch it is so good it's the shop is
gonna be yes so I just want to let you
know and also starting right now today
we are going to be filming every single
episode of sports without balls that
will be on a sports without balls
YouTube page and of course the all
things comedy homepage Emily will then
upload it to our website which will be
up and running and I will give you that
information it should be up I'm not
gonna start big rumors but we should be
ready to go by Christmas of the 2019 you
guys hang in there you guys hang in
there like my Giants like my diamond
looks a big blue
[Laughter]
all right we're gonna kick we're gonna
kick off the show obviously it's been
heavy on baseball
listen right before we dig into other
sports last week's episode was our live
episode from Phoenix so we haven't
addressed the fact that I just sort of
hit your computer i we just both want to
say congratulations to the Houston
Astros we were cheering for the Dodgers
obviously Trish is a Dodger
I'm honorary but I was in the stadium
you guys for Game seven and I'm gonna
tie you at well six and seven six was a
dream sequences Erin would say seven was
the nightmare where you can't wake up
and you wonder what's going on and why
am i standing here and I'm gonna eat my
feelings I hate garlic fries and that
nasty popcorn I almost got one of the
UFO cookies too that's how about I had I
was just eating yelling yeah but it
would look the Astros were awesome I
wish this could have been 77 games I
really do because it's a great series
today we're so fun to watch
thank you for everybody that sent me
such a sweet message thank you to our
awesome fans to that follow us that
we're like hey girl people were sending
me their pictures from Houston from the
parade huggin Altuve and huggin Springer
and I love that because y'all know we're
never hateful mess around here and we
love everybody that in sports clearly
you want your team to win yeah I can't
stand him Brett I'm ready to go ahead
it's okay boys it was about week so he
was planking in Costa Rica with one of
his children on his back because you
know he doesn't really know please I was
like Tommy and quit saying stuff like I
drink a lot of water so I don't sunburn
I'm like you sound mental please quit
and you know I love my Tommy but anyhow
he's great congratulations to the Astros
to the city of Houston it was such a
great series and to my Dodgers I love
you y'all get a little downtime and if
you don't win next year I might have
said this last podcast but the the tweet
I don't know who tweeted it but I think
it summarizes the entire World Series
was if you this is one of the greatest
world
series to watch if you're not a Houston
or la fête and I think that kind of
summarizes said because you know I
couldn't believe how attached attached I
got to the to the Dodgers because God
you know I if I could have spoken to my
sports self years ago there is no way
I'd be cheering for the Dodgers I'd be
all about Houston the story small-market
hurricane like everything in my body was
like go Astros but then when you watch
the Dodgers and you live in LA that team
was just so fun to cheer for and in a
lot of great stories and good kids and I
can assure ya and I just I'll just I'll
end with this it is uncanny and Paul
Sullivan shadow to Paul he's a super fan
and he has his own MLB podcast and
Scully Scully podcast yeah he's he's
great we've been friends forever but you
know it's been this running joke doing
this podcast for the last couple years
now that any big sporting event when it
comes to particularly baseball I'm
either on a cruise ship filled with gay
men that are not playing this board or
or for the last now two years Game seven
has been I host a show for the last
eight years and at the Hollywood improv
it's Maga show it's my sweet gay show
which is nice because all I do is
perform for America which is primarily
straight it's not your fault but I'm a
sweet little gays are uh show it's the
first Wednesday of the improv which
jenny has done multiple times and I got
to get triggered you gotta be right but
this is the second year in a row I've
done Game seven and let me just tell you
the energy of the crowd was negative
seven hundred million because last year
it was bad enough but back in cut in
cubbies but this year it was the day
after Halloween and it was Game seven so
there was probably like ten people in
the crowd uh it's usually about one yeah
it was great there was probably like
maybe eighty people that hung in there
but I had the game on before because I
was like I can't not watch the game yes
probably wasn't the greatest thing as
the producer of the show to have the
Dodgers losing but we couldn't help it
but I have to say I was really being
true
because you know when you're hosting a
comedy show is we've all done before
your party leader anyway first 10
minutes to get them in show that wasn't
percent well I am looking at just
depressed Dodger fans and Game seven
sorry I could talk about for an hour
we'll keep it Game seven was such a
lighter letdown every ending there was
men on baby felt like yeah this is it
and it just
we deserted 13 runs yeah 13 runs and
every time we're sitting there and you
know it was the moment where I looked at
my husband because we I said we have
season tickets so I said to him do we
sell after Game six we're say do we sell
Game seven and just watching at home cuz
and I'll he looked at me and I said you
know what will we hate ourselves if they
pull through and we sold them for like
like money and not that we ought money
matters but you know I'm saying yeah
like will we be that upset that we
weren't here and I and we both at the
same time when yes it was right we're
gone when no in retrospect
no I'm not yeah no I'm not I'll tell you
I tell you we have some weaving their
seats for seven years everybody around
us was a sold seat except the people in
our row and the people on our row have
had the seats for 23 years amazing and
they live in Bakersfield oh my come down
so they usually sell them I'd say 80% of
the time just obviously a challenge but
it's just a tea that they are the sweet
they're the only distributors of
Budweiser to to half of California they
got money as a box but anyway so the
long and the short of course was that I
I was like we got to sit here with
people that it mattered as much to them
right they could have sold them in a
heartbeat yeah and we also didn't have
this moment together where we were like
I wouldn't have traded this moment
because we we love them that much and I
will sit there next year but my husband
and I did on the way home we're both
like we need to just quit sports for a
minute like and he's like and I called
her and told her that miles I think I
think we should take a breed take it up
I'm like I read every day cuz I'm by us
I mean
we take up reading I thought what random
like alright our favorite bar post and
pre or post a game air nose at Mohawk
Bend it's in Echo Park if ya if you
haven't been tried out when you come to
LA we're sitting in Mohawk been eating
and drinking our feelings after ID and
drank him at the stadium and he goes no
seriously babe out honey like maybe like
a self-help / like a-- or what it was
the best of times just jump in to tell
two cities i remember during my first
total horrible breakup with my sweet
sweet karen I've read I read Shogun
because it was like 1400 pages turns out
it was a page-turner but let me tell you
just tell tell Dave to get right back
into a Shogun or a tailor to sedate him
something to just get to Winter Meetings
cuz yeah Jenny my husband thinks he is a
part of the management team at Dodger
Stadium he I mean like I'm like a stand
cast and waiting to call you cuz he's
got computers running and charts um I
doesn't do fantasy baseball like Aaron
respect that if she's got people to pay
no my husband's just worried about the
team that makes us no money we spend
money there anyway well the beauty of
being a fan like such bookies as a lion
fan I'm listening to you cry and whine
about an occasional right into I think
Jenny owns part of the lion and my
husband's from Cleveland originally so
this is why it's such a big deal to him
because he adopted my Dodgers okay
because he's from losers you know it's
get right into that Mike Brown you've
got the Browns you've got his Indians
please and then Cleveland my husband
watches Game seven of the series were
Cleveland one on his phone at night like
a bedtime story it's one of my favorite
sports stories he'll just be also off to
sleep I've already you've already done
this on the podcast but we have new
listeners all the time and at some point
within our NFL you have to do the big TV
at all okay we'll do it still it's one
of my all-time favorite sports stories I
have to end Trish I just want Trish to
hear could she do that she's gonna die
alright so here's how this
Podcast governor is gonna roll we've got
you know we've been doing a lot of
baseball sorry you know whatever we get
to as much stuff as humanly possible but
it's about the halfway mark in the NFL
season and I have been I've been a
little debbie downer
about the NFL obviously it doesn't help
that my team is 1 in 89 which is fine
you can't have a good year every year
this I don't think I've been through
such a I haven't been through a such a
terrible Giants team in a very long time
okay a thank you for love and we're out
of time but this is what I did I want to
show you something and then we'll just
jump into the NFL we've got some women's
soccer we've got some random random fun
stories but we'll do some we'll do some
football we'll get knee-deep into
football Monday I think Monday I had
this like writing assignment so whenever
you get assignments you're like how can
i procrastinate and it and every twenty
seconds i refresh yes Pam calm and there
was an article or no no maybe it was
Mike and Mike the other morning talking
about like the Eli Manning situation
right and you know how I feel about you
ly Manning's I'm very very protective
yes and this will stream into your Lions
and I want you to give us a full report
on the NFC North but this is what I did
you guys I started listing every Oh
every NFL team put that rot in the
camera people tell me to say crazy mess
Oh Monday I wrote down every team in the
NFL and then I wrote down I wrote down I
put the quarterback right I put I put
quarterback I the whole point of this is
this I get real protective of Eli
Manning and I think he's completely
underappreciated and if there was no
Peyton Manning he would be spoken of in
different terms but then I listed every
single quarterback
I just put QB down and I put a strict if
it was
a solid quarterback okay I'd put a like
a like a check if it was like an
up-and-coming quarterback and then like
a squiggly line if it was like a
quarterback or it put an open circle if
there was just basically no quarterback
okay just to prove my point and here is
my point you this chart is heaven take a
picture of it it will be on our social
okay go ahead 11 out of the 32
quarterbacks so 1/3 of the league yes
has no quarterback technically there is
someone under center but they're either
terrible or
it's just a transition or they're been
the quarterback for a year or two and
it's not working so complete and
instability over center 1/3 of the
league that's that's a pretty high
number now
I also listed two tiers I love
consistency just the word consistency
consistency and for NFL quarterbacks is
what you need to win you need consistent
thousand percent Lyons Stafford changing
the culture changed the team change
everything when you know you have
Stafford under center every single game
Tom Brady change the entire Patriots
team then consist you're right and it's
consistent consistency now in two more
two more I'm not gonna say wins because
we probably won't win but two more games
Eli Manning will pass Peyton Manning and
he will be second on the list of starts
in a row second only to Brett Favre
whose number won't be get caught so
here's here's what we have we only have
3 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 so another
third of the league is is consistent Tom
Brady 2001 Ben Roethlisberger 2004 Drew
Brees 2002 Matt Ryan 2008 Stafford 2009
Rodgers 2008 Rivers 2006 even though he
was drafted in 2004 didn't start until
Baco Oh 8 Manning Oh for Alec Smith Oh 5
now out of those 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
only 10 and that is being like you know
at least 10 years in the league
consistency sir
8 9 10 Tom Brady
okay let's Tom Brady's in another
category right so let's take Tom Brady
out of it bend the rothsburgher champ
championship teams won the Super Bowl
twice
drew Brees won at once Matt Ryan hasn't
wanted Stafford hasn't wanted Aaron
Rodgers won Philip Rivers none Joe
Flacco won Eli Manning to Alex Smith
nothing this is the LA I'm just saying
like the lack of disrespect for Eli
Manning is unwarranted unwarranted are
you telling us because you think we
don't agree
no I'm telling everybody through this
microphone into the universe copy okay
cuz we're with you I'm you're preaching
to the choir I'm with you to my partner
on the other hand would would ya holy
disagreement yeah and then he's a bum
he's got no self cons he doesn't have
the leadership he's you know open
mouth-breather he just doesn't have that
mouth he doesn't have that that thing
she says that you know just makes people
want to follow you he doesn't have that
leadership charisma yeah that is her
issue and that is an important position
for charisma however he also has been on
his butt the whole season for seasons
seasons and when we were winning as if
everybody L quarterback some winning you
have to have the most solid oline and
also another thing is when Eli Manning
took over in 2004 he started halfway
through the season and you know it was
pretty bad we hadn't had consistency in
the quarterback since Phil Simms since
the 80s so what I'm trying to say is he
doesn't have the charisma maybe he
doesn't have like a general leadership
maybe you think Oh big bet what would
you take big banner route you take Eli I
think most people go bad
I would but look what Eli has done been
is hurt all the time he has shitty body
languages he women that didn't say
yes there's a lot of things and Eli
Manning's doing cancer visiting cancer
patients I know I know the knock on a
lie but I think he's just a different
it's a different type it's a different
he's a different type
human being and I know he goes against
the you know general and I'd pick a
general you want someone that let you
know anyways a couple years left maybe
not even with the Giants but and then
the other tier of course is this your
new is your up-and-coming and you know
like people that are sort of four or
five years in the league and you're
hoping you're gonna get consistency all
out of all of these Wentz Gough Prescott
Cam Newton David Carr cousins Mariota
Palmer he doesn't count
cuz he's on his way out and he's always
hurt Andy Dalton and Jameson Winston mmm
and Andrew Luck so anyway that was my
money what did you get written not okay
I will put this on social cuz she I mean
it's just sort of a PowerPoint
presentation you would find in a file of
a serial killer one day this will pay my
mortgage I'm not saying is anytime soon
but one day it might be a house on
wheels that can travel and it has its
own removable set but still it's gonna
be a dream board walk in park please
what a day yeah talk to me talk to me
about pre Matthew Stafford and Matthew
Stafford and talk to me about the Lions
and then do the TV which Fela I'll get a
shot too yes I did wear these you know
you're lying
my hearings so good you know what
Matthew Stafford a lot of people get on
the knock they have on him as he can't
win in the big games he can't win in the
playoff games and you know they've won
in my lifetime that was it here's the
thing again it's it's not a one the
quarterback is the most important
but it takes 11 players on every play
it's not just I mean a right field that
can go 3 games and never touch the ball
and you need every player on every play
to play and if you don't have a line
it's just not gonna work we've had you
know Stafford and Calvin Johnson
carrying us through the hole all those
years and we'd get a great defense and
then you know sue messed us up for for a
little while so it's like we just um I
think we still are a couple of pieces
away from like you know complete
dominate to me it was most obvious in
the preseason we were quick for the
first three games we looked really good
then we played the Patriots and it was
just like okay these are the big boys
these are there and and we've come
around and we're playing much better and
we've got an extremely favorable
schedule so I really do think we can
take the division but that being said
it's again it's it's like you said it is
quarterback it is the consistency but
there's just so many factors to lay it
on one guy's head isn't fair no matter
if you're that guy is yes it's not fair
but I'm just saying like you know I
think why every to me like if you look
at the other teams I'm gonna get a hold
of myself I'm gonna put a pin I'm gonna
put a pin in that comment I was gonna do
here's what I want to say a couple a
couple Ryan stuff have you played have
you played the Vikings yet we did we
beat them oh you beat them again on
Thanksgiving which is always good that's
gonna be great being home is gonna be
like and we will be on a roll we got we
have the Browns this week yeah we play
the Browns we have the Bears then we
play the Vikings I believe it is and the
Ravens the Bucs we play the bear the
Browns bears again let's go we've got a
really decent schedule yeah we could
clearly we need Minnesota to lose one
more game but yeah I don't think that we
have a chance and I'm wondering when
Bridge wat if Bridgewater is gonna come
back the season I mean they activated
him I mean he went down at what probably
over a year ago now yeah so that's gonna
be interesting but without Rodgers it
just felt like the whole division opened
up right and now it's sort of up for
grabs out of all those teams I'm on
board I'm a huge Matthew Stafford fan I
I love watching him play obviously
Detroit is just a fun city to cheer for
and so I'm definitely all-in with the
Lions now I wouldn't say that if I mean
Aaron Rodgers is like butter you know
what I mean it's like when I watch him I
will literally go out of my way to watch
Packer games just because of Aaron
Rodgers and and I'll throw the TV out
the window when the Patriots are playing
I will go out of my way to avoid I don't
want anybody to get hurt
but I want a sinkhole and I want Foxboro
Stadium it's probably called something
else Gillette I want your light to fall
into a deep deep deep sinkhole I don't
want anybody to get hurt
no is this before the Super Bowl losses
have you always hated the Patriots or is
it just that that's made it impossible
but I mean the Super Bowl losses the
ones that the ones where you beat them
yeah
where were you that argument are why do
you hate him why I know I just I just
don't I just I just don't I think
there's as much people as many people
that became bandwagon Patriots fans and
I have been a Patriots fan I grew up in
Kentucky we had no professional teams
when I was little I just chose them
because my daddy was a Jets fan and he
would cuss them and I thought you're
being hateful and I thought the word
Patriot meant all-american like in my
mind
yeah and they sucked rocks for a very
long time so I tell people all the time
don't act now I have been I've been
through the mud with this team that's
cuz you love Tom Brady I'm like I have
done Tom that's right serious time if I
grew up in New England I'd be the
craziest Patriots fan but I grew up in
New York and when we moved to Rhode
Island
it was just like Pedro's Red Sox and I
was just like look and so it just became
this like battle with my friends New
York first New England that's that's
what you like the Soviets don't you I
have a soft spot for the Celtics because
my basketball coach thought he was Larry
burden he brought us to the garden when
I was like 13 that's like how do you not
have that still and then of course now I
didn't know I didn't care for them for a
long time and now Brad Stevens like I
just love Brad Stevens but I have to say
this you know it's there if if you don't
cheer if you're not from New England and
you don't cheer for the Patriots there's
just a couple teams growing up sometimes
that you just don't like and you almost
can't just
it's like stupid yeah like now I'm like
my heart I have like a warm like I kind
of like the Eagles ill I think I
actually said that because we look or
some wins you know and he's so feel good
and I like the team I like the energy
around the team I never thought I'd say
that in a million years the Cowboys I
can't Jerry Jones makes me want to set
the stadium on fire with no one in it I
accept him accept I'm not a big fan of
the coach but dak Prescott his dream
sequence Jason Witten he's amazing you
don't I mean well you know I never you
know there's just things you grow up and
then you just have them for life the
Patriots though I have to say obviously
I would be an enormous Patriot and if I
grow up a Patriots fan there's they're
unbelievably fun to watch they win every
year of course you know but as a non
Patriots fan you know just the rampant
cheating but anyway it's I think it's
the same way you focus I've never liked
the Yankees yeah but I was like if I
look back I know like I'll have a dog in
this right yeah I was like you have to
have that moment where you're like it's
just hateful man cuz then you just go
back to him that's the beauty of sports
though you know it Ohio State Buckeyes
you just yes yeah Ohio State everybody
made quite easy I don't I can't stand
Ohio State Stadium I can't even tell you
it's been the heart heart of Marion Ohio
and and when they're out in public
Ohio people if you aren't aware or don't
have anybody in your life that's one of
these people it it happened right we're
engaged so I was already in it we were
going through the Cincinnati or Northern
Kentucky Airport and my husband was
wearing outhouse day sweatshirt to the
airport and these people are passing us
and we're trying to get down the baggage
claim in this girl screams oh H and my
husband goes oh oh walking the other way
that's what they do well they of the go
blue thing in Michigan's it looks that
Kentucky and scream go cats we don't
have a lot to live fluke Ohio's proud
they can spell that word leave a joke
everywhere they go everywhere they go
wow so like I'm the flip side is that
that must have been you must have been
like
kill me yes it was so embarrassed it
wasn't even just embarrassing I was like
is this my future yeah no but on the
flip side as a psychotic sports fan I
love to shout that out in the
airport well I do do it with Kentucky
fans and if I always can tell a
bandwagon win like somebody that just
was like oh I got on board when they
were riding high and they're not real
Kentuckians because real Kentuckians
when we passed each other you go cats
and you put your hand up and you all
high five I don't care if they look like
they're fresh from a bathroom high five
of Kentucky and when you do it to people
that you know either somebody gifted
them that hat or they maybe just got at
the airport and oh thanks and I go I
noticed that in Los Angeles because
there's so many Hunan sports fans here
yeah they just oh my god this goes great
with my outfit yeah a bit cool Olding
yeah yeah and so be like hey go Tigers
David yeah exactly right people will
look at you like you are on fire when
I'm like you got all the doors if we're
something like our guy or a guy in
Phoenix if you see somebody they'll have
a certain kind of a Dodger head on them
oh it's from Latin all a tonight at the
stadium that's what hats from and I'm
like go doors and they will look at you
like my name is cliff yeah and my
husband's super shy and clearly I'd talk
to a rock and scare him cuz I'll be out
places and I'll just he thinks I've met
him or no almond ya know it's sports and
I'm there's a lot of Yankee caps in LA
where I'm like what well we got a you
know brie building here and they're just
like oh ya know I was like okay your
class fall is really exactly right
they're like I just needed this hat and
it fit that by the way is all over
America and I'm not gonna lie I hate it
if you're I have like my ex was a big
she went to Washington State right so it
was like go Cougs go Cougs totally got
into Washington State when we were
together I have a hat it's one of my
favorite hats but it makes me it's it
weirds me out like now putting it on
like you know it's not like I hate
Washington State after the Brit like
it's in a vine but when someone comes up
to me and they're like go Cougs and I'm
like I can't match that excitement
exactly
so I feel weird so I literally just kind
of wear it around the house and whatever
because I feel like if I put a hat on I
I got to back that up right we or at
least be present and aware that you're
wearing that hat that day right yeah or
at least yeah cuz I have my pickles hat
that I probably wear my portland pickles
that I've not gone to see but we love
John Rahn and Sarah Colonna so we
support their pickle excitement and
somebody goes whoa Portland well I don't
associate it I think of it as the
pickles right yeah when they said
Portland I was like oh no I'm
southeastern Kentucky and I was like I'm
at I'm the I was like Oh
pickles yes
yeah but they screamed Portland at me
and I looked at them like they had ten
heads because I was like no part of me
is a craft beer drinking hipster all
come out so I get it can we do NFL week
ten picks and throw Jenni on the list we
can I have I felt like I have a couple
more NFL stuff to do right before before
pics Oh in the meantime I can tell you
what no see I am now a giant fan because
of her might not Aaron because of my
partner oh no no Aaron didn't do that
but you know you want to cheer I I'm I'm
not the kind that likes to compete with
buck I don't if I'm playing my team hey
let's get together and watch a game I'm
like no if they're for the other team I
put for everybody cheering on the same
time so I like the happy tier I detect
so I'm pulling for her Giants and and
and you know as a lion fan you need a
realistic team yeah we can just be lion
fans but we used to need a realistic
team which was always the Steelers who's
my parents from Pittsburgh but I kind of
latched on her tears I instead
everything so we watched it so when we
moved into the house together first
thing we didn't got saddle I got to get
DirecTV package and we had the guy come
out and give us a hundred extra feet of
cable so that we could bring it from the
front room and Britt cuz the lines and
and Giants play at the same time usually
10:00 a.m. the Trinity so we bring the
cable in from the other way bringing a
TV from the garage we have both TVs
going at the same time it's like a bwa
like it's literally a buffalo wild when
you're 11 rockets and then we get and
then you can even get it on a computer
if there's another game you want to
watch you can pull that up on the
computer but whoever has the better
record gets the bigger TV isn't that
awesome
it is literally a buffalo wing I would
come over just to watch magic and how
awesome and so forever the Giants always
the big TV but then I shift is happening
the quarterback Matthew Stafford well
here's the deal is what I actually I
kind of acquiesced because what I found
is I could get my radio broadcast on the
internet but they're about there for
some reason was this weird delay of a
random amount of time so I have to sync
it up so you wait for like a penalty
where they're like holding five yards so
you can see it's e+ e you wait for the
radio to catch up and then you let him
go about the same so then the radio is
synced to the television and that drives
her nuts so then I just take the little
TV and do my little synching thing
that's come and watch my Lions listen to
my hometown because they're they're
cheering for my team to then they're
like touchdown betray oh so much better
than Joe bucking and Troy him for that
but he wins even happy things he won
that was a touchdown everything those
two together is just they're lovers look
at how they look at each other
Joe that would be the only fun thing
about those two if they were making out
do you watch arrabal I hate New York but
I've brought this up a hundred times
have you watched Brock Meyer on IFC yet
please you have to watch it please watch
it watch the Joe Buck episode there's
not that but it's brilliant and it's a
Hank Azaria being washed up it gets a
second chance at life a baseball
announcer and it's on IFC and it is him
and Amanda Peet or the Leeds and it's
absolutely brilliant and they roasted at
a Joe Buck and it's magical and I loved
it and I was like whoever did in
Musburger - oh my god and they're all on
it they are on the show my dad used to
call him Brett muskrat burger I just
remember he's like I can't stand that
Brett Matt mouse rat burger yeah
Lesley Visser and Brent rest Matt Berger
I love
dick Foley's a magical man dick Foley
all right here's a couple things to
players so Ben McAdoo coach of the the
Giants than one in nine Giants who you
see early lost this team I mean you just
lost this team by did he ever have it
yeah why does he even frankly I cannot
believe they hired him it was the worst
hire ever can we say that this to me
still feels like this whole season stems
off of the yachting incident from 2016 I
still feel like I do
I feel like culturally in the Giants and
I don't know the John's like Aaron does
but I remember her lividity your anger
at the yacht sequence it would have
never happened if Tom Coughlin was coach
that's okay that they would have never
it would have never happened so I say I
feel like this entire season stems from
that I want Bill Cowher we need their
kids their kids their 20 21 years old
who doesn't want to like in the oh
whatever
don't get me started laughs game you're
yachting in Miami you would never do it
you would never and he's totally lost
control the team what I don't like is
this to players this morning yesterday
and this this happens on other teams
coming out anonymously and saying he's
lost control of the team nope you do not
do it no B if you if you want to say
about your coach you say to your
coach or you Atlee if you're gonna go to
the press like an idiot be grown say
your name right that's it's so pathetic
so that's not on McAdoo but he it is if
he were ya if he were a better coach if
he were a more strident coach they
wouldn't even think you think they'd do
that for Bill Belichick oh hey oh no
it's not good homeland anyway yeah
no way no absolutely not and oh all
right so that thing that I wanted to
circle back to was when I was breaking
down when it was beautiful minding the
quarterback situation when she was
having her yes of one of the things and
not to hijack with the Giants but this
brings it back to just the the NFL agent
in general
you know they were like what do you do
what do you do about Eli right
do you now though everyone's gonna get
fired think out well I hope they keep
Steve Spagnuolo because the defense yeah
wonderful McAdoo's call offensive
coordinators gone I'd get rid of Jerry
Reese because in the last three or four
years his drafting has been absolutely
terrible I'd get rid of Reese I'd clean
house and so the report came out a
couple days ago that Mehra co-owner gave
the signal to start looking at college
quarterbacks oh so we've got David Webb
who he took in the third round I think
he came out a cow we don't know anything
about him because he hasn't played and
I'm not saying towards the end of the
season do you bench Manning and give
Webb a chance to see what you got in a
two and eighty-five season I don't have
a problem with that it almost seems like
better business as long as you know but
is that a fair test though because again
I mean it's a test right it's a test
where you can't really simulate practice
so you got to throw them in at some
point is it a fair test no but it's you
got to put them under fire the speed of
the NFL you have to but here's why you
do not do not let Eli Manning go at
least for another year because if you're
not if you don't if you don't believe in
David Webb okay fine draft draft someone
in the first round right
second round whatever you got to do and
maybe he's the quarterback you're hoping
to be the quarterback of your future but
the fact that you still have Eli Manning
who could give you another couple of
good seasons and look how much time they
took with Aaron Rodgers why would you
put someone in that's completely
untested in the NFL right with a
oline no run game a defense so we can
get murdered look I mean no receivers
and no receivers I mean they'll be back
next year but like look what happened to
happen to Andrew Luck yes he did turn
the team around 11 five eleven five
eleven five something like that
but he's had more injuries than anybody
and now now he's legitimately like
they're like oh my god I hope he comes
back because of all the hits and all the
in offseason
now season-ending shoulder surgery I
just I just don't see
how you can just I don't see how that's
the been a benefit to the team
I really don't and if you cut a lie you
know just we're going with like you know
Baker Mayfield Baker Curtis Mayfield
Baker Mayfield out of Oklahoma Sam's
Arnold who I don't think is ready to
come out of USC I think he needs to test
another year and Aaron was slightly
stalking him the lobby I was so I get
very shy I needed Trish I needed my
wingman she's come up in with that
southern charm and be like hi we were in
Phoenix and that USC was playing Arizona
State and they were saying in our hotel
and Aaron almost had a stroke because
the entire lobby at one moment was
filled with the entire USC football team
and like she's talking and clicks I
think like like Blair like was or Blake
Lively Ryan Reynolds wife is behind us
I'm like clearly it's got to be the most
dream sequence woman I've ever seen I
turn around and it's the entire USA
football team and I was like not the
reaction I was expecting
she's like crazy but she did coroner
half of them in an elevator it was magic
I did and I told them I thought the
benefits of playing for the New York
Giants if they get drafted nobody wanted
to hear it okay anyway I real quick I I
just wanted to say yeah yep sorry that
was a little moment about something
that's trending in the news that's gonna
make everybody happy and disgusting
anyway here we go and we're back I just
I just here's just one more thing
Cleveland Browns the Cleveland Browns
have had the number one pick for the
last 15 years and when golf like all
they pass they pass they pass on these
quarterbacks and you're just sitting
there like I I mean if I was it so the
whole report was I think it was darn old
that a bunch of people were like they're
waiting to see if Cleveland gets number
one because it's gonna affect whether
they go literally back to college or not
Darnell came out with that
yeah and I thought yeah I mean people
would rather go to class and go to
Cleveland that's how bad it is your your
you literally go like they will not come
out of college because they don't want
to but I think there's your answer to
about whether or not you're just it's
not I don't think whether or not you
keep Eli is as important as your GM I
mean I could speak from experience with
we got Bob Quinn former Patriot yes and
we have turned around since then and he
was smart enough to keep called well
because and I was kind of iffy on Cobo
myself but but he's really you know
proven I think to get a good demeanor on
the team we got rid of sue got rid of
fairly got rid a lot of the
troublemakers I'm gonna change the
clubhouse culture and have somebody that
can drive a bus yeah I mean that's the
Troy but so I think you need to get a
better GM that's gonna do put all of the
pieces better in better in place
together so that's to me yeah I think
you're right and Reese needs to go and
the and the whole staff if I don't know
if spec know Lea he was a head coach and
you know but I wouldn't make no yeah a
head coach I'd keep him as our defensive
coordinator but I'd get a disciplinarian
in I mean we've got Odell Beckham jr.
the dude needs discipline serious no he
needs to be Roger Lewis was also on the
yacht I mean come on this is just like
no yeah no totally agree and also like
Landon Collins who's like my favorite
he's just like Abby's he's like always
up for like is this his second year and
he's like practically like MVP I tell ya
I saw that Rams Giants game on Sunday
and I was like I thought my two things
Eli Apple overrated Landon Collins look
like honestly legitimately he gave up on
a couple of the routes into how fun are
the Rams to watch meantime thoroughly
Todd Gurley hot garlic I'd girlie I'd
put him in dream sequence you know they
did a poll of six NFL players up for MVP
and it's like you know he's the only non
quarterback Todd Gurley is a beast I
think I might adopt the Rams on Sundays
they're my defense on my fantasy team
how's your I also wrote down in our
Trish update on your fantasy team well
I'm not doing like here here's the thing
and this is the most jacked up excuse me
it's real truth I've ever said when we
were in Phoenix our waffle was spotty at
best in our hotel so we had issues and I
couldn't make moves so I screwed week
nine up like nobody's business
oh no doc yeah it was I don't want to
talk about it and you know and I had
people that run a bar and I couldn't
move people from the bye week and like
you know just cuz I was like is this a
joke so I went from in standings just so
you guys know I went from third I went
from third to tenth Oh
in one week trash I don't want to talk
about it okay just it wasn't oh no I did
I did I I could I could I couldn't I
could I hated it from it's very
inception and went back in America today
but I'd be out on the road and the first
thing I would do when I would find the
cities find a sports bar and you'd be in
the sports bar and there'd be somebody
cheer and from my lions with me and then
they'd be chair of the other team really
what the hell and when it first came out
it was like well now I've got the team's
defense or whatever so it made me so mad
because again the most team sport the
epitome of a team sport sort of break it
up like that just drives me I tried I
did I did two years and my apartment
looked like yeah look like a war zone it
looked like your apartment I had I had
like radio I had a computer I had red
zone I had and I was miserable yeah I
was absolutely miserable and then I
co-owned a team in a cone-like helped
out this guy's team and he had Dez
Bryant and I remember Dez Bryant caught
a you know TD and the answer yes oh my
god
exactly and I walked away that's that's
like a bottom yes
do I trade okay all right guys you've
got to nerd NFL nerds left and right
what can we do do I move out asthma in
the wide receiver position I did it's an
auto pick so don't judge my team I have
DeAndre Hopkins or do I move switch them
out for John right now I have sorry let
me go back I'm talking like a crazy
person I was looking at him is if it's
not open 3:10
Jordy Nelson he's got no one to throw to
him I know so I've switched it out for
DeAndre Hopkins from Houston a lot
Houston has no one yeah I know we can
trade for somebody it is Blake
everybody's done on a stretcher at their
Lian
we're playing Cleveland yeah hey Cole I
know I'd have just me okay I'll get back
to you
you got a you at a full-on can you got a
full-on drop Texans and Green Bay
receivers and even pick up like a second
or third stringer on like even the
Giants because all these guys are
getting do you get points for yards or
just scores two scores
how about even like a third string
around like the Raiders I mean they've
got I'm sure Crabtree and the other ones
taken Cooper but isn't that was the
third one on the Raiders like I'd look
into that let's look at wide receivers
y'all who's available this is exciting
for me I'll let you look it's so much
easier to let you look in certain I mean
everybody off this is my this is my life
I get and it's a dandy one shepherds
Shepherd's available Oh grab Adam right
now I'll have this kind of Tom I'm Arnie
stressed out we've got tonight we've got
the Cardinals I mean we're already there
Cardinals and is it you can talk do you
not see you can't send me you gotta send
me this I just need to add you in and
give you my son on stressing me out I
just went from third to worst I hope
it's an auto pick it's not your fault
well but I but I've seen thank you for
the cosign of mine well see the problem
is like this like this one jumps off the
page like you're like okay you could you
know Drew Brees is on fire Ted Ginn jr.
like that could be a good pick but then
you think Buffalo Buffalo's defense is
really quite good Sammy one thing I
dropped Texan defense and all I have
left is Rams defense so I need a backup
defense for her I don't even if the Bob
wake situation is of Rams already on
their bye week anyway I feel like I'm
laying in a shuttle and I've got a lot
of crap going on I'd pick up Sam
Sheppard I'm hitting the dingus were
playing the 49ers and they're not good
hit all right yeah that's true that's a
good point
well you're okay pick them
life away and then wait are these and
this is the rest of your team right here
now you're on hold on you guys this is
what we're doing then let's do pics
let's see cancel we're back here's my
whole team let's go back to Trish's team
and we'll do pics Aaron what uh what
what time are we at we are at 48 36 oh
wow okay we got to keep this moving
that's the team as it stands if you want
to take a quick look igloo and then
we'll go right to week 10 pics I'm ready
to hit that this is can you can you take
pictures and send it to me I will
screenshot it more because I'm gonna get
real distracted I'm gonna have to go
into stats and see who they're playing I
love her so much when do you have to put
it has to be done before nights 39
through this do you have to do them all
before tonight or just tonight's before
tonight
no all for tonight's you have to be set
by Thursday they will let you so you
have to be set for like if if I have
anybody on my team that's playing
tonight yeah does that make sense like
if they're in the lineup and they're
playing they have to it has to be then
you can do it again on Saturday you have
them by Saturday again - oh so it's just
tonight so you just have to get your if
you're picking anyone right right a
Seahawks and Cardinals oh so you just
have to pick Hawks cards cards by
tonight if you have if I have anyone
exactly right all right can you
screenshot I will do all that and we can
go ahead and do week ten
all right week ten perks which is part
let's do the first one which is tonight
Seahawks at Cardinals okay so Jani
here's what we found with the picks I'm
gonna break this down real quick the
first time where I was really like
talking out the picks it was an hour and
a half uh nobody needs that nobody well
I mean we've just done ten minutes we
can kinda see the team recent fantasy
team that I just may or may not be
successful all the way to wait none in
third place that's very good that's a
big deal that's a quitter but if you're
in lasted 10th yeah it's only 10 I just
I just determined what we should do with
the patreon is
an extended nerd version of pics for
extra footage all kinds of stuff so you
guys all kinds of stuff happening but
here's what also I've determined
I will psychoanalyze the game for an
hour and a half Trish will go bills and
the bills will win so um it doesn't
really apparently doesn't really matter
apparently you can come up with 17 hours
of quarterback picks and just pick one
with those yellow socks and they win so
that's my sister does it well I like
this city better oh that bad I just tend
to absorb my sports information kind of
like the movie Slumdog Millionaire you
don't remember how it came in but you're
like okay the bills and then they win
and they're like why did you know that I
was like I was on the phone with my
girlfriend summer and then the wide
receiver coach called her husband
because they've been friends since high
school and like weird happen he's
like so-and-so's not in today oh don't
work that's how my brain Trish third I
feels her pics I do ah which not sure
how Slumdog Millionaire fits in there
but but the lack of parity would be one
thing cuz of a weird information that he
remember and everybody's like it was
fixed and he was like no she's weird
crap that happened then he remembered
that's how I my life is I'll go hi oh my
God why do I know that and I'm like let
me go on the archives sometimes I felt
like Jason Bourne meets eleven okay Wow
Scheffer pass someone with a jersey and
then you you go back into your head and
no matter what what jersey it is and you
go who's that player yes in what team
and then you have to get it in a certain
number of seconds cuz you have to turn
around before they leave I noticed that
the other day someone's talking about
you see what somebody was wearing like I
don't pay any attention to fashion
unless it's a jersey and then I in
passing tell you who they were what team
it was yeah a whole deal yeah how long
they were there often you're on a game
show you're like I have to get this
booze in ten steps he's gonna be in his
car or he's whatever or she and then
you're like who is it who is it Ray
Allen I love you for that I know it's
fine but you know what I mean
alright so so anyway point be speed
speed speed sex
speed and we're gonna do errand gut
speed we call him gut speed picks Aaron
myself and then you and I'll turn very
quickly and the second team listed is
the home to is the home team and we're
gonna start with the Seahawks and the
cards
Seahawks cards are terrible they'll
probably win I'm sorry in my mind I did
it hawks Seahawk you know what I'm gonna
go up I like Drew Stanton when he was a
backup at Detroit I liked him I'm gonna
go in their home and and I don't like
Seattle so that's a I love that kind of
attitude Saints at Bills Saints at
Bill's I'm gonna say Bill's come back
after the devastating loss to the Jets
they're not in a dome I'm picking Bills
Bills Saints oh I love that Saints could
totally win Bengals at Totten oh I
wonder if anybody's gonna watch I'm
gonna go with the Titans I'm going
Totten I mean - just cuz they're home
yep and it's just off the CMA Awards
honey and they love one country good
things happen to me that's when my
that's when my southern shows okay sorry
did you watch them last night I did I
did I hate country music but I did it
just to see if anyone said anything
about Trump I just fast forward did you
like the opening number though I thought
they did a really good job
they wrote every damn country star I
mean it was lit wouldn't be as if at the
Oscars you put every major actor on and
they all just did a group monologue
that's what happened Wow was it seven
hours no it wasn't too bad but Garth
Brooks did lip-sync which was fun and he
owned it he got Entertainer of the Year
and well you know good Garth is great
okay we've got steal I'm sorry I missed
one Chargers at Jags at Jaguars Chargers
at drag wars let me tell you this a
feline man and gets cut Tom Coughlin is
GM at Jaguars they need consistency at
the quarterback their defense is one of
the best you know I might be a Jaguar
and then I'll have to move to
Jacksonville picking the drags
I picked the Chargers I'm gonna go with
the Jags I can't stand Phillip I know
but you know sometimes you just gotta
it's kind of like playing at home the
Jags churches aren't that bad they
I know I'm filling it Steelers at Colts
Steelers Steelers Steelers alright I
hate to do this to you Aaron Johnson
honors two and eight Giants I'm gonna go
ahead and because I love you John all
right Jenni McNulty he's in case she was
listening I'm gonna have to go with the
Giants that's love or you're four feet
away from Aaron Foley either way you're
saving lives my own primary primarily
but that's still sweet okay my paths at
Broncos perhaps at Broncos pets pets New
England I love that you make it all
sound class here Jenny those
piece-of-shit pants I share a birthday
with Tom Brady led by a couple of years
but we're both August there's something
good happening on we're very big about
birthdays and sports around here I say
it on I know though yeah and I Erin
because my birthday I share with Tiger
Woods and LeBron James oh we all are
December 30th
so we're big nerd so I love that you are
with me Tommy and he went to university
Michigan where anyone's Leo's are magic
I've got Jerry Rice summer Sanders
that's right that you know that Carol
Carol look up September 13th Carol I'll
get right on it for you in the meantime
Jets at Buccaneers she's just started
chugging it right now she'll get back to
us
uh what is the pick Jets at bucks
the Bucs are just I'm sorry than
Winston's the Winston's not playing did
you see that malarkey that happened with
Mike Evans and Jameis Winston on Sunday
no it's just Jameis Winston showing his
true colors and if you
believe that whole hard knocks good luck
cuz he will disappoint you his entire
career because I think he's a piece of
you doesn't matter he had a tough
upbringing hashtag crab legs we all had
tough I know his upbringing somebody uh
Mike Evans coming out of nowhere in
blind time that guy you could have
paralyzed him wait who they boys the
backup quarterback good in Tampa
Jeb Mary Foley ears so the job I
don't know I just can I pick the Jets
but I don't know what the boxes that's
it would remember when it was Sean King
for 25 years I don't know I don't know
Carroll we need September 13th and we
need the backup for the Tampa Bay do not
flip me off in public she's really very
lip here if she is a huge country music
fan and on it
she's been hungover all week since
Phoenix since Phoenix uh you know what I
don't I'm going jet house disco Jets
I'll go jets you know I just I wish I
knew who the backup was because
sometimes they can turn around and have
a great surprising game and they're at
home but yeah I'm gonna go with Ryan
Fitzpatrick oh oh no I changed my pic
I'm gonna go with the Bucks he's got a
he's got something to prove let me just
tell you the home never
I'm Jenny this is why you're a great
addition totally switching pics going
with Ryan Fitzpatrick he'll have a chip
on his shoulder for the just letting you
know he's got a fantastic - I'm going
with the I'm going with the Tampa Bay
and it's home home is a big thing in
home is a big thing yeah and also the
Jets suck
no offense because I Love New York but
they stink the once in a while I'll pull
off a win but I'm going with the Bucks
on that one
Thank You Carol for telling us it's Ryan
Fitzpatrick alright what's up next we've
got brown cat line sound at home that's
a tough one Lyons I'm walking out if any
of you pick Cleveland lions
this is the week the Browns get the
first one of the season are you on
Detroit it actually
surprise me with they would take over
the Owen sixteen or tie us with Owen
sixteen I'm going with the lines okay
how do we feel about Packers at bears
remember when these used to be good
games you know what I mean like the
height of the I just I don't really have
a lot of confidence in the Bears and I
think I don't have confidence in the
Packers either but I I'll go with the
Packers I'll go with the Packers but
that I don't I don't
it's kind of sad that's why I'd like my
feelings on the NFL are like because you
feel like all these superstars are gone
I'm going with the Packers I'm doing
Packers too you know what else I'll be
cool smoked cigarettes with you guys in
the bathroom go with the back okay
Vikings at Redskins party people Vikings
at Redskins this is going to be
legitimately good game yes you know I
would switch it out that's to me to me
I'm gonna go with the Redskins
home-field advantage I think they're a
little bit more of a consistent team but
the Vikings are hot great deal that's
really good
that being said I'm gonna pick skins
skins and I'm wishing for the skins
we're doing it y'all how about Texans at
Rams Texans at Rams this would be a
great game if Watson was in and JJ Watt
was in and the Houston had a full team
I'm come on the Rams bandwagon here
I think the Rams will pull that off I
agree Rams yep yep it's Rams they have
to their monday fans
I need this this is why I hate football
you think you have a patriot and then
they just they're not I'm not I'm now
Carol just sent me this when you google
famous athletes born on September 13th
I keep getting Tyler Perry you do sir it
was Tyler Perry and ironically Stella
McCartney the day comes back around like
full circle why am I not getting any
athletes and Fiona Apple I got one for
you you're gonna love it
Bernie Williams I knew that I've said
that on air before I'm an idiot you're
tired I have the greatest Yankee robe
ever it's it's for an extra-large man I
don't wear it a lot but it's got 50 it's
a pinstripe robe with number 51 on the
back Bernie Williams of course sweet
Bernie and Niall Horan of the One
Direction I love me some boy bands I
know you do you also have a daisuke
daisuke matsuzaka
you're professional snowboarder and a
beauty Jamie Anderson she's a stunner
okay okay I'll take Bernie Annie Duke
pro poker player sure Michael Johnson
track and time Michael Johnson I'm
taking Michael Johnson to Bernie and I'm
gonna let go of the Boston reliever all
right let's keep this moving what do we
got what do we got and Tyler Perry we
can just keep holding on a Tyler Perry
Ray Charles oh oh those are cute those
are big deals no time Britney hey hey
we'll take my sweet sweet sweet sweet
Bernie
you've got Cowboys at Falcons that's
well in the in the spin the wheel if
Elliott is playing I mean I haven't seen
this and and that's why Jerry Jones
what's good Goodell out the 69
suspension of Elliot lady did they could
even improve anything and even if it was
it would have been the guy not Tom and
he serves for games yeah this guy beats
a beat someone up 16 times in one week
so gross he's the grossest and is
actually today heed me I want someone to
tackle him and go yeah or just throw up
on his face or that we're really through
I just I just and let the Falcons have
just been so disappointing they just
they lose big
there's no consistency there I mean you
know you have to give home-field
advantage is pretty huge in Atlanta
listen I'll say this if Elliot plays I
think I'd I'd pick the Cowboys if he
doesn't play maybe I'd pick the Falcons
can you make those conditional picks yes
you can we that's how we roll
so everybody's Cowboys unless of course
Asterix scroll down we don't have
because I do believe we're recording
this on Thursday I'm going to put it out
tomorrow also a shout-out to will do a
u.s. women's soccer plane you look it up
if they've ruled yet it was opposed to
be at 11:00
Oh hold on Carol Faith Hill and Tim sang
together she got excited she was texting
me the whole time it's she's back to the
capri just literally doctoring up her
Capri Sun loves a Capri Sun poncho
that'll be my conditional okay all that
I put asterisks next to all of us so
Cowboys across the board in because
unless of course is EQ lately it's not
playing
in the meantime dolphins at Panthers
that he can play Sunday so it's Cowboys
are you kidding me wait a minute
yeah what we didn't know that saccharine
yeah no I don't think so that's why he's
still saying I was gonna Jerry Jones
wants him out right isn't that so mother
it's well they're voting on it again
today they're voting and voting whatever
the hell they're doing I don't know we
don't know we don't know all right let's
keep this moving dolphins at who
dolphins at Panthers mmm Panthers and
it's cam in or is he questioned by gonna
look he's out for the season
can't Cam Newton no he's not oh no I'm
sorry I'm having a stroke that's wishful
thinking
yeah that's sorry it's Jameis Winston
that I had that I had to draw it's a
thing sorry I was back to my own no
problem team again apologize I liked him
and now he's I'm gonna have to
begrudgingly pick the Panthers it's just
my Christian McCaffrey that I love so
much I like him oh I love him I don't
have the chance to get him so bad yeah I
have to do the Panthers because it's the
Dolphins I mean I mean
what else would you choose Panthers Oh
Panthers yes okay and then we've got
that was it that was my Monday night
game okay uh I know we're Aaron what do
we got for time Oh crapola
all right here's good we got a scoot
let's do this there are a couple stories
we did not get to so just some quick
shout outs I wanted to do kind of like a
super fun heavy football one while we
have Jenny if you don't love football
it'll all balance out in the wash and
Monday we'll be back to a host of a
right because we've got the NHL we've
got hockey season starting we've got a
couple weeks into the NBA and all sudden
the Celtics are winning without Gordon
which is super fun also I'm going deep
with women's collegiate sports because
this is the area where there's no
women's a lot of women's professional
sports so I'm gonna go deep and we're
gonna do some UCLA UCLA USC collegiate I
just found out the UCLA women's soccer
is playing San Diego State at home on
Saturday for a soccer playoff am I going
to make that game go Aztecs go us UCLA
why can't I say UCLA Haley I actually
went to that school all right
another thing is this airs tomorrow so
it won't be informative for today but it
will be informative on November 12 the
US Women's National Team
they have friendlies in Vancouver with
Canada there are going to be great games
today 7 o'clock November 9th well we're
recording and then Sunday November 12th
is the second friendly so if your
women's soccer fan this will be probably
the last two friendlies of the year I do
believe I had to have to fact-check that
so I'm super pumped about that because
you don't get a lot of you know off
years non-olympic World Cup years
they're doing more and more friendlies
which is just the most exciting thing
ever another
a couple congratulations egg
congratulation Adel done who I love so
much
married her partner it's all over ESPN W
go to ESPN W actually on our web page
right now ah just put it on her Facebook
page stunning can I just tell you guys
like her dress changes and I salute any
woman that does two dress changes the
dress changes I love because I didn't
love the dresses but I love the dress
yes their reception gowns
boom I'm like yachts they're so stunning
both of those of them and that like that
just love I mean it just was the whole
thing was beautiful and it's covered on
the knot and anybody that's done hard
time on the knot website whether it's
been a registry or you know it's great
it's beautiful but they just did such a
beautiful job in covering their wedding
and they're both just stunners and they
threw a gorgeous event but the dress
changes and yeah I'm assuming the one
shot when you guys see it and the story
again on our sports without balls
Facebook page it her mom tell did you
see that short with her mom I'm not sure
if I saw the show with her I'll pull it
up I'm like Hello apple tree stunning
just gorgeous anyway you can't even and
then a another massive mega I was
texting Erin after it happened she was
why are you calling me at this hour but
to Shailene flanagan for being the first
american since 1970 that's her feel-good
moment of the week what yeah okay do you
know that she has foster children yeah
but we have we have two improperly
introduced it sorry
well you can cut me out it's on the
video you know I got so excited what's
the time code just for the podcast at it
109 so in the land of video you guys get
to see that sometimes I get so excited
I'm like a toddler with a pixie stick I
didn't mean to squash your glory or your
joy your joy it's just I was gonna rap
with doing wedding and then present the
feel-good moment of the week which will
all be presenting we had a lot of
feel-good this week and if anybody's
know any feel good nobody was back on a
bus this week oh but they were well well
we'll save it for my
day yes listen just a the car going on
to the bus another Lavar ball child
might be under house arrest in China
just you know Li Angelo Li Angelo they
need their own what did we say they need
the Pharos yeah the balls the balls the
balls need a bus the ball family needs a
bus that's why we are officially called
sports without ball there yes sports
without the ball family yeah we'll keep
you posted on the hot breaking story of
Li Angelo's trapped in China Jesus
Christ that family's ridiculous maybe
Donny can bring him home yes right
[Laughter]
listen right before the the the
feel-good moment of the week well just
to congratulations to delle donne
getting married or partner is wonderful
I care no I'm glad she get married she's
gorgeous
I'm glad she's gay I'm glad she's on the
team yeah if she'd have married the of
the NBA star Dellavedova and kept his
name she'd be Elena Delle Donne
Dellavedova which would have been fun
very amazing I almost cheer just cheered
for a straight couple just based on
names does he have a sister because that
would be epic oh my god that's amazing
yeah Thank You Jenny for that you went
out of happy say that one more time it
was amazing Elena Dellavedova dela Elena
Delle Donne Dellavedova it just would
have been so amazing amazing wranglin
for this and also for me going down the
court like for this reporter they'd have
to be like just II he gets the ball okay
biggie gets the ball maker also a
congratulations to Caroline Wozniacki
for getting engaged to David Lee
formerly of the Golden State Warriors
he's it's a little bit of a journey man
I always liked him
he was a Knick for a while in the you
know just in the heyday
but Bosniak II I have always liked and
even though she doesn't like Sharapova
my sweet sweet sweet Maria Sharapova a
little bit outspoken about that but
whatever
but anyway Wozniacki had that kind of
heartbreaking rory mcilroy where the
wedding invitations went out and he
called off the engagement it was such
terrible heartbreak so I was very happy
for her and also I would be remiss if I
didn't say this and this is so
heartbreakingly sad that we're gonna put
it in between love and the feel-good
moment of the week Roy Halladay passed
away I I was so shocked and stunned and
saddened he was a Toronto Blue Jay in a
Philadelphia Phillies two teams I can't
stand and I loved him and I loved
watching him pitch hall-of-famer I
remember in the 2009 series being like I
can't believe we have to face him twice
because they played the Yankees just an
absolute pleasure to watch talk about
like master of complete game now and
these playoffs people are like oh god
help me get through five we can only get
through the starting pitcher through
five he just would be complete game
complete game complete game one of the
best to ever pitch to songs like so far
apart yeah I wasn't like he got an
enroll and you know yeah and I don't I
watched the report this morning I don't
know if you saw it but that plane that
he was actually flying it was an ultra
light plane and basically it was it was
touted as like a jet ski with wings yeah
so they are saying it was pilot error
because he actually crashed him four
feet of water oh my god so and somebody
on a fishing boat the sweet fisherman
that got over to the boat right away
thinking dear God if there's some you
know obviously there's someone flying it
let's get to them they have the video
the like 30 seconds before and he was
flying really erratically so I think he
was trying when you watch the company
who made the plane and forgive me for
not remembering what it's called
but they show you know the way you can
land it almost like a hydroplane right
so they land on water and land land and
write it like a jet ski
and so he's doing all these like kind of
weird maneuvers that you're like did he
pass out behind the wheel like you're
thinking that but I think it was him
really trying to bring it down and take
off and then of course the company
released that there's three people that
have died from this plane in eight
months and the other one was the man
that created the planner of the plane
yeah it just you know what's so sad
because your immediate reaction you know
because whether you love the athlete or
not yes it doesn't matter as a human
being and I loved Roy Halladay I think
most people did he was revered is you go
why was he flying plane was it fun was
it nothing good happens when you're not
a pilot and you fly a plane but then you
read the story and he loved it more than
anything it was five what's his favorite
thing it and so you're like of course
you want to do something you love you're
retired it's just your first my first
instinct is like why and then I also
thought please someone call Nia and get
bill burn never to fly a helicopter ever
again he tells a main joke not sure how
he lands on top of a helipad we love you
bill bar I just we love bill burr and we
don't need him to ever fly a helicopter
or plane ever again didn't you say la
Bamba oh wait he wasn't flying just
every how many examples do I mean John
Denver JFK jr. like nothing good happens
real Idol Cory Lidle Peggy Stewart even
though he wasn't flying yeah but just so
terrible anyway I guess it's you know 40
years old I guess it's it's the silver
lining is what an amazing career amazing
family you do you you do you pass away
doing what you love and also to
everybody else get up early and make the
most of every second of your life
because you just don't know what's gonna
happen and that is probably a really
perfect segue into the feel-good moment
of the week take it away Trish Suhr
because this is this is one of my one of
my all-time favorites for so many
different reasons we are so so so I mean
the goober level was DEFCON 4 in
congratulations to the amazing Shailene
Flanagan for her when the New York City
Marathon the first American
mel american since 1977 she has the last
10 years never won a major marathon and
this is what she does she's an Olympian
in the sport right this is this is her
rodeo people she is an unbelievable
human being she really is she has two
foster children who are in track and
field which third all babies and she's
like they actually care you know like
this matters like this this year
fostering teenagers teenagers and the
first thing she said of course when she
came across the finish line she wanted
donut I was like we might be kin but I
love it because I for years had followed
her because I ran a bunch marathons in
2013 ran followed her eating plan
because she eats super super super clean
yes she has a book that she go eat fast
cook fast shut up run fast
cook cook fast eat slow eat slow and she
and it's great and if you ever want to
pick up something you don't have to be a
marathoner clearly I'm not to follow it
but she's just such a class act
and it was just this nice beautiful
button on everything that is going on in
this world at this time to see her win
that race I just also you know she was
running the Boston Marathon when the
bomb went off yep
and four or five days before the New
York City Marathon which I thought God
are they gonna pull the marathon but
after after 9/11 that that New York City
Marathon was the greatest day of her I
you know the horrible attack with the
van just the terrorist attacks happened
that week and and she above all was like
I want to do this for New York I want to
do this for the u.s. like it means but
like crying crying sobbing crying
sobbing the fact that she can be so
eloquent and put herself I mean
obviously you wanted this you're our
premier athlete your goal is to win a
marathon you not only win the marathon
then you put yourself and you go I
wanted to do it for everybody else and I
just I can't get enough of this woman
she is like beyond a role model and also
New York City marathons are always super
special because my twin sister and four
or five New York City marathons and it's
a day where every the city is out I'm
telling you there is not a mile in that
race and it spans over every single
borough except for the Staten Island you
know goes into Queens it goes into
Brooklyn you're in mahat you're in the
Bronx people you you almost in some
sections can't even get close to you
know people are high-fiving people are
in costume it's one of the greatest days
in New York City and then after the
tragedy the first u.s. and also women
women just the spirit I mean look what
happened on the election on Tuesday I
mean women are kicking ass so good so
good revenge of the suburbs I said I
send to Aaron because I was so freaked
out as soon as it happened you know I
instantly sends it send it or on social
media but Aaron does not answer the DMS
you guys so I don't even know I have
them she didn't yeah so the night a text
her and say check your dams and she's
like are you watching me through a
window so anyway I had sent her I said
oh my god did you see as she leans Tom
and she was like what happened I said
basically she finished the New York
Marathon y'all wrap your brain around
this she finished it in two hours 26
minutes and 53 seconds that is just
under a six-minute mile by point yeah
it's five point six one yeah I mean
Graham Island 5.0 I could do it in ten
my whole have been point to time body
was put in half my brother is a Navy
SEAL and he runs his 623 and he can only
do three of them at 6:23 unless there's
a gun then maybe five but I was like
about that that's a gun to your head you
know it's you know it's weird though is
is we are in such a weird place in our
society with all the violence and
everything her comment about I was just
hoping they didn't catch me my first
thought when she said it wasn't that
they would catch her running it was like
catcher what you do what like some sort
of criminal element involved in the race
I'm like oh no catch her on the plan my
motivation was I robbed a bank right
before I started the New York City
Marathon and I was running for my life
literally and my freedom that's the only
way I could complete something well
that's I mean when
we did the math and I sent her the time
and I you know cuz I was like I'm not a
math genius
when I saw two hours in 26 I'm like that
feels fast decided to break down and if
y'all don't know Amir sick marathon is
26.2 miles so after doing the numbers
and I saw that it was five point six one
you know
just under six miles a minute I went
that's where my head went I know what my
brother runs to be the 1% of the 1% that
saves the world this woman just saved
the world what she ran I someone was
literally chasing her life while you
were crunching numbers I texted gal
gadot and she said her six point three
eight so this she beat Wonder Woman she
beat Wonder Woman she is actually she's
a modern day we salute you
you guys I put this article feel good so
you're good
and Sheila's brother ran the marathon
this year too he finished in just under
five hours you know you can watch it on
yeah well so we watched him cross the
finish line it was so cool to gives you
in track him I don't know all the little
funny thing that happened cuz Kevin Hart
comedian Kevin Hart who is a great comic
father great dude he ran it this year
yeah yes he did
and so did a man named Kevin Hart from
Hollywood Florida so a bunch of people
were on line thinking they were tracking
and he was like 51 running it was his
birthday and yes it's so congratulations
to both Kevin Hart's for winning the
race every person you finish the week
everybody that competed as an American
it's amazing it's amazing that is our
show we ran a little long I apologize I
don't you could shout football but um
you know what you you made listen in all
fairness when you're doing this on some
downtime
you still love football yes I will be
taking a picture but Jenny thank you so
much for coming on the show
anytime ladies come back where can
people find you and will link all this
into the episode oh Jenny McNulty eg in
an ie McNulty dot-com on Twitter it's
Jenny McNulty Instagram it's McNulty dot
Jenny accountant and Bismarck took it oh
we wish him evil will link all of that
stuff but go see Jenny
McNulty perform your hilarious
free my podcast who if I may throw to
myself is walking funny I'm doing the
walking funnies again so we got to get
you good ladies I have a comedian but I
also a degree in exercise science I'm
trying to get people exercising so what
I'm doing is I'm interviewing people
instead of this sit this lovely setting
I take a walk with them and I encourage
the viewer download it walk along with
us so we courage them along the way
awesome so check out walking funny and
that's all on my page and stuff too and
you will send me that and we will link
all of that that is absolutely fantastic
I'm sorry we didn't even get to talk
more about that you'll have to come back
and do that we didn't get to the box you
guys you have to come back for the box
of cards totally alone Jake okay come
back towards the end of the season we'll
do more horrible do more football the
box of cards and all good things Trish
we sort of know where to find oh yeah go
to Trish Suhr calm and I'll be doing
that I'm yeah doing TV crap right now
yell you know when you feel like you're
just a weird box and can't tell anybody
what you're doing I'm being held in
protective custody tell yes she's got
all kinds of exciting projects and Erin
koat.com I'm in LA most you know oh yeah
I've got a wide open calendar I'll be in
Phoenix or Glendale Arizona the 14th
through the 17th I'll post those dates
next week we'll be back in then we'll be
off Thanksgiving week because I'm gonna
be shipped out to Florida
hanging out with Mary dick but I think
that is it do we miss anything any final
words we'll be cheering for the Lions
the trees I said it it's okay for you as
a human
we'll be a gym for those Cardinals in
the offseason sports without balls fans
friends family have the best week of
your life
God that flew body you guys are